Donald Trump is now panicking about the
increasingly likely scenario in which
his tax returns leak he spent the
overnight on his platform truth social
essential call it whatever you want uh
complaining and telling lies let's back
up just a little bit there's two things
going on simultaneously later today the
January 6 committee is expected to
announce uh which criminal referrals are
they sending to the Department of
Justice Trump may be on that list we
don't yet know that's number one
separately the house Ways and Means
Committee has finally obtained Donald
Trump's tax returns Trump spent years
trying to keep them secret for a guy
with nothing to hide I haven't seen so
much money spent trying to keep those
tax returns secret Trump is now worried
that the tax returns are going to leak
and he clearly is worried
I believe because he thinks that the
subject the content of those tax returns
would be bad for him so he goes on Truth
Central last night 10 11 midnight and he
starts quote the highly partisan
unselect committee is illegally leaking
confidential info to anyone that will
listen Adam's Shifty shift is all over
TV talking about Capital C criminal
referrals just like he was on the
russia-russia Russia hoax which turned
out to be the con of the century how
much longer are Republicans and American
Patriots in general going to allow this
to happen these are the capital c
criminals who spied on my campaign
cheated on the capital E election lied
to fisa court in Congress they are sick
Trump then when Trump starts these rants
it's often like okay what's this what's
this about what triggered this his next
post exposes what this is all about
Trump says quote you can't learn much
from tax returns but it is illegal to
release them if they are not yours Trump
worried about his tax returns being
released it's also not true that you
can't learn much from tax returns tax
experts have said you might be able to
glean from tax returns that Trump's not
as wealthy as he claims to be that he
has debts to Shady figures that might
have him compromised that he is engaged
in tax fraud
and a number of other things Trump
continuing quote all of the so-called
experts who think that they know so much
about my very successful private company
actually know almost nothing it is a
great company with lots of cash and some
of the greatest assets anywhere in the
capital W world and very little debt
also strong on deductions and
depreciation you will be seeing these
numbers soon where have we heard that
before from before but not all from my
tax returns which show relatively little
everyone will be impressed but the fake
news media will not be happy so against
their narrative
is anybody still falling for the we're
gonna release the documents very soon
thing I mean that's been going on for
almost eight years at this point
Trump continuing the real criminals are
the people who were destroying our once
great Capital C country and Trump
closing it off election interference by
the FBI and Twitter was massive and
determinative how sad of course that's
not true but when in doubt go back to I
guess what's been working for you which
is claim you really won
more than two years ago
oh boy if the tax returns leak this guy
is going to go cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
and I look forward to it I would never
encourage anyone to commit a crime or
leak anything but if the tax returns
leak it's going to be quite a scene
folks this Friday we are doing something
we have never done before Friday
December 23rd yes we're doing a
membership special it's the last
membership special of the year but
here's the incredible thing we are doing
your first month's payment of this
discounted membership will be donated by
us to a charity that they don't run it
through this huge complex process where
at the end of the day 45 cents on the
dollar get to the people we're trying to
help we are going to be donating the
first months of everybody's memberships
uh this Friday when you use a special
coupon code to a charity that sends cash
to people who need it and we're talking
people who really need it people living
on a dollar a day to like two dollars a
day okay in addition the money is going
to be doubled now I can't say exactly
through which charity because if I did
it creates a marketing situation where a
contract it's just complicated so what
we've been told to do is David just
promote it this way and then on Friday
you can announce what you're doing with
the money once you already have it okay
so that it's for legal reasons we're
doing it that way
how do you get notified about all of
this this is unbelievable you will get a
membership at a discount and that
discounted payment will go to people who
need it and be doubled we've never done
something like this before I want it to
be really successful get on my mailing
list at davidpackman.com top right of
the website you'll see a place you can
type in your email you do need to know
your email address for that to work
Friday morning you'll get an email
telling you here's the coupon code
every payment going to be donated and it
will be doubled it will be matched
dollar for dollar up to the first
fifteen thousand dollars which I think
is going to be more than enough for for
our purposes I'll talk more about it
we'll take a quick break and be back
with much more from the news of the
weekend
everything you do online can be tracked
by your ISP by Tech platforms the
government hackers everyone should be
using a VPN every time you connect to
the internet you turn it on once you
forget about it it's easy many vpns
secretly record your browsing and
download history but our sponsor private
internet access is the only VPN with the
bulletproof commitment to never doing
that because they're the only VPN that
has proven their no log policy multiple
times in court their systems are also
independently audited by Deloitte to
verify no logging private internet
access has a Next Generation server
infrastructure with IP addresses in 83
countries and all 50 U.S states it's one
of the only vpns fast enough for
streaming video and downloading large
files for instance private internet
access lets me access a bunch of great
international soccer I can't otherwise
get VP ends can be very helpful with the
upcoming World Cup and private internet
access has a 30-day money-back guarantee
24 7 customer support and my audience
gets 82 percent off that's just two
dollars and 11 cents a month plus three
months free go to
piavpn.com David the link is in the
podcast notes